>> THIS IS OUR BEST CHANCE TO
BEGIN REBUILDING OUR MILITARY
AND MAKE PROGRESS ON ISSUES
DIRECTLY AFFECTING THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> IT’S A GOOD DEAL FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND IT’S A
STRONG SIGNAL THAT WE CAN BREAK
THE GRIDLOCK THAT HAS
OVERWHELMED THIS BODY AND WORK
TOGETHER FOR THE GOOD OF THE
COUNTRY.
>> Chris: SENATE LEADERS
MITCH MCCONNELL AND
CHUCK SCHUMER BUSY TODAY PUSHING
THE BUDGET DEAL THEY NEGOTIATED
TO AVOID ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
LET’S BRING OUR PANEL.
JONAH GOLDBERG OF NATIONAL
REVIEW.
MARA LIASSON FROM NATIONAL
PUBLIC RADIO.
BRIAN KILMEADE, COHOST OF
"FOX & FRIENDS."
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLER
"ANDREW JACKSON AND THE MIRACLE
OF NEW ORLEANS, THE BATTLE THAT
SHAPED AMERICA’S DESTINY."
MARA, THE BILL, THE BUDGET DEAL
STUCK FOR THE MOMENT AND FOR
SEVERAL HOURS ON A PROCEDURAL
ISSUE IN THIS SENTIMENT BUT EVEN
IF IT PASSES THERE, THERE’S REAL
QUESTION WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
HOUSE WHEN HE GOT OPPOSITION
FROM BUDGET DEFICIT HAWKS AND
DEMOCRATS WHO WANT TO SEE THE
DREAMERS INCLUDED.
WHAT ARE THE CHANCES TOMORROW
MORNING WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN?
>> I THINK THERE IS A CHANCE WE
COULD HAVE ONE.
YOU HAVE TO GET OVER THE
PROCEDURAL HURDLE OF RAND PAUL
WHICH I THINK IS DOABLE.
IN THE HOUSE, PAUL RYAN WANTS
THE MAJORITY OF THE MAJORITY,
ABOUT 118 REPUBLICANS TO VOTE
FOR IT.
I DON’T KNOW IF HE’S GOING TO
GET THAT.
THE FEWER REPUBLICANS HE GETS,
THE MORE HE NEEDS FROM DEMOCRATS
AND THEY ARE NOT IN THE MOOD TO
HELP HIM OUT.
THEY WANTED TO GUARANTEE.
NANCY PELOSI LOOKING FOR A
GUARANTEE FROM HIM THAT HE WOULD
BRING UP SOME KIND OF DACA
LEGISLATION.
SHE HASN’T GOTTEN WHAT HE    SHE
WANTED.
SPEW ENDEMIC
AT DEMOCRATIC LEADERS NOT
PUSHING TO VOTE NO.
SOME LEADERS THINK THEY ARE
GOING TO VOTE AGAINST IT.
>> SHE SAID THERE’S A LOT OF
GOOD STUFF IN HERE FOR DEMOCRAT
DEMOCRATS.
SHE IS NOT WHIPPING IT TO GET
HER MEMBERS TO VOTE NO BUT SHE’S
NOT PERSONALLY VOTING FOR IT.
>> Chris: THIS IS GOING TO
BLOW UP THE DEFICIT.
THIS IS WHAT THE BUDGET DEAL
WOULD INCLUDE.
DEFENSE SPENDING OVER TWO YEARS.
ANOTHER $160 BILLION FOR THE
MILITARY AND STATE DEPARTMENT.
131 BILLION MORE FOR DOMESTIC
SPENDING.
90 BILLION IN DISASTER RELIEF.
20 BILLION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND 6 BILLION FOR THE OPIOID
CRISIS.
TAKEN TOGETHER, THAT’S MORE THAN
$500 BILLION OVER TWO YEARS,
ADDED MILITARY AND DOMESTIC
SPENDING AND THEN ADD THE TAX
BILL WHICH IS GOING TO COST
1.5 TRILLION OVER THE NEXT
DECADE.
COMPARISON, THIS TOTAL OBAMA
STIMULUS PACKAGE, YOU TURN
$35 BILLION.
AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE, DEFICIT
HAWKS ARE FURIOUS.
>> IF WE SUPPORT THE RECKLESS
SPENDING WE HAVE FOR SO LONG
CRITICIZED IT WILL MEAN AN END
OF GENERAL         GENUINE FISC.
>> Chris: WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
G.O.P. AS THE PARTY OF FISCAL
DISCIPLINE?
PEOPLE HAVE TO SAY WE CAN BE
FISCALLY DISCIPLINED.
NOTHING GETS DONE.
NOW YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
LEADERSHIP SAYS WE HAVE TO GO
FIND THE GOVERNMENT.
WE WANT TO GET A TWO-YEAR DEAL.
THEY WATCHED SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE MATTIS COME OUT AND SAY
THE THING THAT’S HURTING OUR
DEFENSE AND THE PENTAGON WORSE
THAN ANY OTHER ENEMY IS WHAT’S
HAPPENING IN CONGRESS, NOT FULLY
FUNDING US.
WE CAN’T EXIST LIKE THIS.
WHAT PAUL RYAN AND
MITCH MCCONNELL SAY IS THEY WANT
DOMESTIC SPENDING.
WE WANT DEFENSE SPENDING.
WE GET THIS MONEY TO DOMESTIC
SPENDING AND IF YOU LOOK AT IT,
A LOT OF IT GOES TO WHAT THE
TRUMP AGENDA IS.
INFRASTRUCTURE, IT GOES TO
OPIOID, CANCER RESEARCH, YOU GET
THE TRUMP AGENDA MOVING FORWARD
ON ONE HAND.
THEN YOU FULLY FUND THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT FOR TWO FULL YEARS,
AND THEN WHAT YOU DO IS DO
ENTITLEMENTS AFTER THAT.
IT’S THE AUTOMATIC WITHDRAWAL
FROM THE BANK ACCOUNT WHICH IS
HURTING US, NOT THE
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING.
>> Chris: I ALSO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE SPLIT AMONG DEMOCRATS.
YOU’VE GOT CHUCK SCHUMER, LEADER
OF THE DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE,
SAYING THIS IS A GREAT DEAL AND
THEN NEAR OF NANCY PELOSI WHO
HELPED NEGOTIATED BUT NOW SHE’S
AGAINST IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I HAVE AN UNEASE WITH IT AND
I HOPE THE SPEAKER WILL MAN UP
AND DECIDE WE IN THE HOUSE CAN
ALSO HAVE WHAT MITCH MCCONNELL
GUARANTEED IN THE SENATE, A VOTE
ON THE FLOOR.
>> Chris: JONAH, HOW SERIOUS
IS THE DIVIDE AMONG DEMOCRATS
GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT CAN’T
PASS THE SENATE OR HOUSE WITHOUT
A LOT OF DEMOCRATIC VOTES.
>> I THINK MARA IS RIGHT.
IT WILL PASS IN THE SENATE.
IT WILL JUST TAKE LONGER.
IN THE HOUSE, YOU HAVE THE
PROBLEM.
WHAT NANCY PELOSI DID IS AN
EXERCISE IN VIRTUE SIGNALLY.
THE BASE OF THE PARTY DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO GETTING SOMETHING
ON DACA.
SHE CAN’T FORCE ANYTHING SO SHE
WANTS TO BE ON RECORD WITH SOME
BIG SYMBOLIC SHOW.
ON THE ENTITLEMENT THING, I
DISAGREE -- ONE OF THE REASONS
IN SUCH A GREAT DEAL FOR
DEMOCRATS AS IT WOULD MAKE ANY
POSSIBILITY OF REPUBLICANS DOING
ANYTHING TO RECONCILIATION
POSSIBLE.
RECONCILIATION, .
>> Chris: THEY NEED TO PASS A
BUDGET.
>> THERE IS NO WAY THE
REPUBLICANS ARE UNABLE TO DO
ENTITLEMENT REFORM AND GET
ENOUGH DEMOCRATS TO VOTE FOR.
BASICALLY GUARANTEES THE
REPUBLICANS GOING INTO 20 TEAM
WILL HAVE NO OTHER BIG
LEGISLATIVE ITEMS ON THEIR
AGENDA.
THEY’RE NOT GOING BE ABLE TO DO
ANYTHING OF THE FIXES TO
OBAMACARE THEY WANTED.
THIS FOR THE REASONS WHY
CHUCK SCHUMER REALLY LIKES THE
DEAL.
EXCEPT FOR THE DACA PART, THERE
IS NOTHING THE DEAL THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULDN’T LOVE, AND
THERE IS INDIVIDUAL SPENDING I
CAN DEFEND, THIS AMOUNTS TO A
DEATH KNELL MESSAGING.
>> A LOT OF DEMOCRAT SENATORS IN
RED STATES.
AFTER THEY GET IT DONE, THERE’S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF SAYING I
NEED TO BE FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
YOU NEED ABOUT EIGHT.
IF THEY GET THE BUDGET THEY WANT
AND THERE’S THIS SENSE THEY WILL
GET SOME TYPE OF DACA DEAL, WHY
DO YOU THINK WE CAN BE A LITTLE
BIT OPTIMISTIC PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO SEE WELFARE IS A MESS.
SOCIAL SECURITY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
MEDICARE.
>> I’VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION TO
CONGRESS FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS.
>> IT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS PROMISED NOT
TO CUT MEDICARE, MEDICAID,
SOCIAL SECURITY.
YOU DON’T --
>> HE SAYS HE’S GOING TO BUILD
THE WALL.
THEN HE SAYS HE’S GOING TO USE
TECHNOLOGY.
HE COULD PULL BACK ON IT.